Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook and let's get going, okay?
Today's theme is this: Holiness is the destination of the
universe. Now we're in the book of the prophet Zechariah today, and
Zechariah 14:20 specifically. Let's read.
"On that day, 'Holy to the Lord' will be inscribed on the
bells of the horses, and the cooking pots in the
Lord's house will be like the sacred bowls in front of the
altar. And every pot in Jerusalem and Judah
will be holy to the Lord Almighty, and all who come to sacrifice
will take some of the pots and cook in them.
And on that day there will no longer be a Canaanite in the
house of the Lord Almighty."
Holiness is so integral to the plan of God
that he intends to make all things holy.
In the Old Testament, God begins moving closer and helping
his people understand what he means when he says, "I am holy,"
his own holiness. But because the blood of Christ was not yet shed to
provide that holiness, God's presence would bring judgment,
so he creates barriers, walls that contain his holiness.
So a tabernacle, a temple of a most holy place.
He creates things that are specially cleansed and washed,
consecrated by the blood of bulls and goats as an illustration of the
blood of Christ. So he sets apart a certain race, a certain
priesthood, to interface and connect with his holiness.
But through his servants, the prophets, Zechariah, he looks
down through time and points out a day that things are going to be
different. Someday, the line between what is holy and common
will be erased, not so that everything becomes common,
but so that everything becomes holy.
Holiness means that we are privileged to erase
that line today. We don't have to
wait. We get to see God's future plans for his kingdom
come to pass in our hearts now. By the power of
God's Holy Spirit, we live out right now God's eternal
purpose for the destination of all things.
So everything now can be holy, that everything
now that is common can be sanctified to God's
ownership, that everything now that is corrupted can be
put away,
and everything in my heart can be made holy to the Lord
now. When Christ died, something really impossibly
big happened in the temple. The veil that separated the
two parts of the temple from each other, the most holy place, was torn in
two, and in that moment two things happened.
First, we had access by Christ's blood into the
full presence of God, the full glory of his holiness.
But I think there's an aspect of it that goes even deeper.
Yes, we have access to the most holy place, but that's because the
most holy place has come out to meet us.
Like the shockwaves traveling out from a nuclear blast,
God's holiness has come out to meet us.
It used to be that in order to know God's holiness, we had to travel
deeper into the circles that God had created to contain, and
yet now the circles have come out to us, making all
things holy as God's glorious holiness touches and
consumes all the parts of our lives.
Now the temptation of worldly Christians is to erase the line between
holy and common so that everything becomes common, to use
grace as a cover for whatever I'd like to do.
But I'm here to tell you that you can go the other way with it.
You can erase the line between holy and common by realizing
that everything in your life that God has laid claim to, it
is his, it is holy.
And that is the destination of the universe.
There's coming a day where it will be that way.
Did you notice in what we read that it points to very ordinary things?
It talks about the bells of the horses and the pots,
and it says that they'll put food in the pots and cook.
Do you see the ordinariness
of holiness, right? There's no part of your life
that God doesn't rightfully claim as his own.
Gone are the days where we say, "Well, this is my sacred life,
and this is my secular life.
Now my secular life is on Monday through Saturday, and my sacred life is
on Sunday." Gone are the days where we worry about if we're doing
enough holy things. "Am I doing enough holy things?"
We sometimes draw sacred and secular as two different circles, and we worry
about how much they overlap or how much time we spend in each
one. But God says, "Let me tell you where the whole universe is headed.
It's headed to a place where the whole universe, even the
most ordinary things, are touched by and
claimed by my own holiness, where nothing's
ordinary, everything is holy." Now I want you to notice
it also says, "No Canaanite." You see that?
"No Canaanite will be in the house of the Lord Almighty." The
Canaanites were idol worshipers.
They were ones who lived immoral and unholy lives.
Can you imagine a place, a world, where nothing is unholy and
no one is unholy? What a world, right? What a world.
So here's my invitation to you.
Why not now?
Why not be a center, a connection point, a place
where holiness invades the world through you?
Why not let it be that way in your heart right now?
Let the most holy place
invade the secret areas of your heart and take control of
all of it.
The veil is torn, and you have access into the most holy place.
By the great sacrifice, the most holy place
has access into you.
Now you say, "Well, how? I can't do that. Am I blocking it?
What do I need to do?" Okay, I'm glad you asked.
We've started into delving into these scriptures, and we're going to spend the
next, oh, 10 days talking about how God
produces holiness in us. But for now, just determine this.
You've got the right glasses on, and you've decided that your heart,
the destination of your heart, is going to match the destination of God's
universe, the full glory of his holiness.
I was reading John Wesley's journal the other day, and I saw this quote.
Here's what he said. He said, "I was asking in the evening that God
would fulfill all his promises in my soul."
Yes .
Yes. That's it. Oh, if you and I could ask the
Lord, "Oh God, fulfill all your promises
in my soul." I don't want anything held
back. I want to be wearing the kind of glasses that says, "Lord,
I want you to fulfill all your promises in my soul.
If I see something here, Lord, I'm asking that you would make that, for
me,
reality, you fulfill every promise in my soul."
So let's just begin by recognizing that holiness means,
the will of the Holy Spirit who's in you,
is that your holiness would continue to increase, and that
God, the holy place, would invade all the parts of your heart and make it
all holy, all right? So we're going to talk about how God does that in the next few
days. I'll see you then.